I thank everybody for coming
I appreciate the fact that we passed the
house version of the budget Bill hb1 and
hb2 then it went to the Senate they've
made a lot of changes and the expert
that's going to
brief on those now is our legislative
budget assistant Michael Kane and his
staff that that we couldn't do a budget
without them are all here handing out
papers so you'll have something to look
at when he briefs it take it away Mr
Kane
thank you very much chairman Weiler just
for the record and those who don't know
me my name is Michael Kane and I'm the
legislative budget assistant for the
State of New Hampshire as representative
Weiler stated we worked with the house
in the month of March in the beginning
of April to pass their budget uh your
budget and then we work with the senate
in April all the way through June and
actually
they beat tomorrow to take a vote on
their budget so they're still
technically working with the Senate I'm
going to go over the Senate finance
committee recommendation I can tell you
right now that as you know there will be
floor amendments there'll be debate
there'll be other negotiations going on
as I'm talking so this may change but
this is going to get the 99 percent of
what they're going to work off of so
Senate finance will turn to page one
both the house and the senate had a
beginning balance from 23 of
361.4 million dollars in the general and
education trust fund uh the total
revenues uh estimated senate had three
177.9 so it's almost 60 million dollars
over what the house had and we talked
about during the house phase is the
Senate it has the benefit of later
Revenue collections in the March and
April Revenue collections which are your
two largest months for business taxes
meals and rooms Etc so they did have
additional Revenue total Appropriations
the Senate also had lapsing there was
about 30 million that lapsed from House
Bill 2023 which was the energy relief
bill that was passed last fall and the
30 million of that will last so the
Senate was the benefit of that lap so
those two amounts right there was over
100 million dollars that the senate had
in the general fund in education trust
fund that the house did not total
Appropriations to the senate about 3.3
leaving accumulative ending about 201.8
they're transferred to the rainy day
fund was 68.7 million dollars is the
current estimate it was 69.7 but then
the Senate did pass the bail
um the bail status system bill in House
Bill 610 of a million dollars that took
them down from when Finance added so
68.7 bringing the rainy day fund balance
to 228.6 at the end of 23. your balance
after transfers since it's a combined
statement this is your education trust
fund anything remaining at the end of
the fiscal year in the education trust
fund carries forward into the next
fiscal year any balance remaining of the
general fund at the end of a buying and
has to be transferred to the rainy day
fund unless suspended by the legislature
it wasn't so that will add 68.7 million
to the current 159.9 million dollar
balance bringing it to 228.6 we're still
going to watch uh there's you know we're
only in June the beginning of June it's
going to be June Revenue collections we
know that the Senate weighs means
Revenue estimates if
the state hits plan in June for Revenue
collections they'll be at the Senate
estimates almost to the dollar so as we
get through the middle of the month if
the you start to see that the revenue
estimates are above for the month of
June that's additional money that's
going to go into the rainy day for under
carry forward to the education trust
fund depending on its source
so for 24 the only beginning balance is
the education trust fund house had about
183.8 Senate 133.1 and I'll show you why
they had that reduction when we get to
those lines total revenues house had
3127.9 senate had 3194 so almost 67
million dollars of additional revenues
over the house
total Appropriations the house had 3.165
Senate Finance 3.097 close to 3.1 Keelan
of ending balance at the end of 24 the
next fiscal year
229.4 between the general education
trust fund the share the general fund
share is 42 million in the education
trust fund share is 187.8 million
and before I go on one of the big
reasons we'll start to see it when I
have a separate General and education
trust fund Revenue there's a difference
between the amount of business taxes
that the house proposed going to the
general and education trust fund
remember the house had 77.5 of all
business tax collections going into the
general fund in 22.5 staying in the
education trust fund the Senate
kept the splits or put the splits in
statute at 59.41 which is their current
law it's roughly the current law
percentages that are split between the
general and education trust fund as a
result as we get to 25 you'll see that
the Senate is going to have a much
larger balance in the education trust
fund the house to uh main reason is
because of that business tax split
decision that they had
so beginning in 25 the beginning balance
of 229.9 in the Senate compared to 145.7
in the house additional revenues over
the house the Senate ways Means
Committee estimated 3.165 versus 3.11 so
that's another 55 million dollars of
additional general education trust fund
what the house had when they were
developing their budget
cumulative ending balance at 239.5 the
house had 5.4 however the general fund
share of the balance is 3.2 million of
that 239.5 that general fund balance
compared to a house balance of 5.4
million uh Senate did not suspend rainy
day provision so the 3-2 goes into the
rainy day if one bringing that balance
to approximately 231.8 the
236.2 is what stays in the education
trust fund so that's at the end of 25
based on the current Revenue estimates
based on the current education funding
proposal and other uses of the education
trust fund that's the balance that the
Senate leaves the ETF with
so you've probably read or heard
um you know if you were following Senate
Finance uh Senate President with a
couple of his statements in public about
reducing The house's budget by almost
three quarters of a billion dollars so
how do they do that we have and just
kind of step back a little bit when the
Senate began their budget process in
April they still wanted to wait until
the end of April before they made any of
their final decisions so they could see
revenues the Senate as you know
typically gets higher revenues because
they have the later Revenue estimates
but they began the process saying that
we need to cut the House's budget so
this was the Senate when they discussed
in public we're going to try to reduce
the House's budget this was before
knowing what revenues were they were
comfortable getting below the governor's
number getting below the House's number
but they wanted to get there in a way
where they could still support a lot of
the house initiatives and do things
typically what the Senate does and as I
get to those I can I can show you
there's a couple
mechanisms items that are used to bring
the total budget down and as we get
through those lines I can let you know
one of them if you look on row four it's
just an example one way to bring the
24-25 budget down is to fund any
one-time cost into 23 and because the
revenues for 23 were so robust
with the over 480 over plan probably
going to push over 500 over plan for 23.
even though the legislature appropriate
almost 200 million dollars in the in 22
out of that balance they were able to
absorb some of those costs and so you
can see in row four where you'll see an
addition of 1.2 million dollars for
moving and fit up costs for das
administrative services and you can see
a reduction in 24 25 so that's one way
they're getting down to that 750 million
dollar figure that the goal they set for
themselves you can see another repeat
Das maintenance there were some
maintenance fund costs that the house
did provide 3 0.6 million a the Senate
decided to support that but to fund it
in 23 again just those two items alone
brought down the Das Appropriations by
about 4.8 million but you both the house
and the Senate both get to the same
endpoint
you'll see on row nine House Bill 1 to
House Bill 2 case management system
house decided to fund a case management
system for the child advocate in 2425
Senate supported that but funded it out
of FY 23 funds so that's the 201
and then we get to the big numbers how
did you get to 750 million you would
probably think you would open up the
budget and see large cuts a lot of the
programs that you put in that are gone
um on row 13 the meals and rooms
distribution has statutory Authority is
a separate fund to distribute meals and
rooms to the cities and towns and that
exists off budget it existed off budget
in 22 and 23 so as you were hearing
things about budget growth the house was
actually taking a hit of almost 240
million dollars for showing an item that
was off budget coming on budget in 24.25
the Senate decided to keep status quo so
what they did is They removed the
appropriation Authority in house bill
one
recognizing that they already have the
statutory authority to appropriate all
these funds and distribute into cities
and towns off budget with the current
statute it also pulls out one thing that
the Senate talked about during their
deliberations was when you have a meals
and rooms distribution or any
distribution we have or percentage of
tax restricted for a certain purpose as
you're developing your next budget or
your next budget in your you know you
need money somewhere maybe you have a
general fund shortfall you're going to
look to those restricted accounts to try
to grab that general fund Revenue to
have this off budget as it was a big
decision that the Senate made and that's
one of the main reasons why they made it
on row 14 the treasury the sheeted
property so these are all the abandoned
claims or the abandoned property
that individuals who they have a right
to usually this is an open Journal fund
warrant that's off book you don't see it
I'll show it to you on your schedule too
or will account for it during the budget
process of these general fund
Appropriations
but the treasurer put that into
um House Bill one and two and so that
brought the budget up by about 5.2
million over the biennium however that
statutory Authority already exists what
the Senate do is they did set up an
account for a sheet of property in the
budget of one dollar so when we get to
the 26-27 budget in in the next plane
and you'll see at least historically
what they paid but that is something
historica has been off budget has been
off budget for decades and the treasurer
came and worked with the Senate finance
committee to get language and to still
accomplish what she was trying to
accomplish with that
um
if I go to row 15 reduce the affordable
housing fund to 20 million dollars the
house had 30 million dollars to the
affordable housing fund Senate reduced
that to 10 million dollars it's hard for
me to comment on the reasons why they
make that reduction you can talk to the
individual Senators but there was
discuss that right now you have five
million dollars of real estate transfer
tax that is transferred into the
affordable uh housing fund every fiscal
year so that's taken out of your general
fund revenues already and so in
recognition of that 10 million dollars
it's already going into the affordable
housing fund over the binary the Senate
reduced by 10 million that was one of
the reasons they used
17 the group 2 transition Provisions
these are the group two changes to the
group two retirement Provisions that
went back to the pre-2011 or 2011
statute when they made all those changes
in the retirement that was a 50 million
dollar cost for the house well to get
the budget down that was one of the
large items that the Senate discussed
and debated one of the last items that
they made a decision on in Senate
Finance which will still be debated
tomorrow when they have the budget come
before them but they removed those uh
that change and they did establish a
study commission with four Senators four
house members and various other parties
to look at not only this issue but
various other issues impacting the
retirement system as well as retention
of state employees through retirement
benefits
the next 9 18 deletes the pay down or
the uaal the unfunded Actuarial
liability in the retirement system
there's close to five close to six
billion dollars the house put 50 million
dollars in general funds to pay that the
Senate removed that and then you'll see
them allocating various other
Appropriations so they had a decision to
make do we support that where do we want
our rainy day from to be at the end of
23 and how does this play into our full
picture so there's a lot of meetings a
lot of discussions that are happening
I'm involved in some not involved in
others just to try to get the the Senate
comes up with a plan and tries to get to
where they're all comfortable if at the
end and so that was one that
um fell down on the priority scale with
the Senate on row 19 New Hampshire
retirement system amending the group two
Cola group two had a cola put in by
division one that cost about nine
million dollars the Senate decided to
instead I think they did it a few years
ago where it's a 500 one-time allowance
for those retirees who have been retired
for five years who are group one or
group two and who have
um at least 20 years of credible service
pension benefits under forty thousand
dollars or under they'll receive a
one-time 500 payment
that one-time allowance is seven million
dollars versus the house nine million
dollars for the group two so there's the
two million dollar difference there
and I won't go through every single one
of these so don't worry uh row twenties
two hundred thousand dollars was
Centerville 125 relative to Regional
Economic Development grants with an
annual appropriation so that was one
thing that they did put into 24 and 25.
when we go to Category 2 administration
of justice and public protection there
was some small changes for judicial
branch about 750 000 uh there was but
one drug court that the judicial branch
forgot to fund and didn't notify the
house the Senate was notified and were
able to provide funds so that each
company can have their drug court
funds Farm Ranch dress assistance two
hundred thousand dollars that was the
Commissioner of Agriculture coming to
Senate finance and requesting additional
funds that weren't requested from the
house
row 29 3 million dollars to Child
Advocacy centers that was a big ad in 23
for 23 surplus funds that the Senate did
and just to kind of step back a little
bit when the you're appropriating 23
funds when the legislature appropriating
23 funds what they do is they hit your
current Surplus with a current fiscal
year and then make those funds
non-lapsing until the next biennium but
what you're doing is you're basically
grabbing those before they go into the
rainy day fund that's what 23
Appropriations do from the general fund
so there's 300 million there uh internet
crimes against children 800 000 that's
on row 31 and then I'm just going to
skip some of the bigger ones but if we
go to on row 35 you remember House Bill
639 this is cannabis legislation it was
something that had an appropriation that
passed after the house finance committee
had adopted their budget this was a
separate bill went through ways means
and passed and had almost a 15.6 million
dollar general fund appropriation with
the Senate's position and vote on that
bill because it's itl they were able to
save when you compare house to Senate on
the Surplus statement about 15.6 million
just because that bill right now did not
pass
rows 36
Rose in 37 a relative to
um again similar to ways means a lot
smaller scale but renewable energy
funding Greenhouse Energy Efficiency
fund right now has statutory authority
to spend to appropriate in everything so
it's separate then all a lot in
household one which are the initial
authorizations for spending it already
exists and so the Senate removed those
understanding that those funds are still
going to continue to
um
operate as they do now it does bring
them down closer to that budget goal
that they set for themselves
40 is the Surplus statement adjustment
on our side and the LBA so you'll see an
increase in the lapse and I'll get to
that in a little bit and that has to do
with the energy bill that passed in 30
million of those funds not utilized
on page three
so Rose
42-46 I'll talk to kind of all at once
this is the judicial Council so those
members on house finance that have been
here for a while uh know that when their
judicial Council comes in one of the
areas which would be reduced first for
General funds was the judicial Council
and the reason for that is because the
judicial Council can come back that one
of the few agencies that can come back
to the fiscal committee and request
additional General funds if their
Appropriations are not sufficient so the
senate in recognition of that reduced
their budget not to the 22-23 levels it
reduced it to your their 23 actuals
which are what they were appropriated
plus what they came through the fiscal
committee so you can see on rows 42
about 2 million dollar reduction a year
and then some smaller ones and then
you're going to see on 45 and 46 and so
what happened here is that the Senate
did reduce the public defender and did
reduce abuse and neglect fund sorry
contract Council by about 1.2 million in
for contract Council another 5.6 in the
public defender but judicial Council
came back and they asked the Senate if
they'd reconsider that action if they
would put the funds in the Senate was
still holding firm that you can will
give you what we got in 23 you could
come back to fiscal and negotiations
continued and then you'll see in 23 that
the final decision made by the committee
was almost 6.8 million dollars in the
current surplus funds there that can be
used by the contract Council and public
defender if their budget is not
sufficient so it's kind of getting to it
now instead of coming back to fiscal
later for those two lines big reason for
the public defender as you all know is
that is a contract the public defender
does have issues with finding attorneys
and compensating attorneys to provide
that defense and so that was one area
they were willing to fund
50 and 51 is more just a reflection of
the legislative process there are things
there are items in hospital one and two
that may also have a separate bill going
through the legislative process and
depending what happens to that bill
there's going to be some actions in
hospital one and two and vice versa
here's one we will have on row 50 a
million dollars removed to the bail
condition status system from house bill
2. so that when we did the initial
Senate Finance Surplus statement it was
a little
um the Appropriations were one million
dollars lower but because in row 51 and
House Bill 610 there was a floor
amendment that passed on the center
floor the next day to fund that system
out of that bill so it's something that
came back onto our Surplus statement and
that's how if you were to look at the
531 Circle statement in the 6-2 that's
the change right there and then there
was another bill that I can talk after
about it had to do with the Department
of environment services at division one
bill that was retained so that saved
about 250 000 from the Senate position
back on last week
northern border Alliance was added back
that is something as you remember it was
in the governor's proposal deleted in
the house proposal Senate right now has
1.4 million dollars again we are this is
the Senate finance budget proposal there
will be discussion on all these items
tomorrow I'm sure there'll be floor
amendments on some of these items as
well row 53 is funding DMV protective
glass was a hundred thousand DMV came in
and had close to seven million dollars a
request the house thought well I mean
the senate senate finance will give you
your most important so priority wise was
to get that protective class
row 57
on row 60 uh the fish and game fund Fish
and Game fund ended the house budget
with a positive balance I think it was
in the four to five million dollar range
um
fishing game came back to the Senate and
asked them to fund the pay raise so can
you fund instead of having Fish and Game
fund the pay raise that is in the house
bill too can you fund that for uh fish
and game so we don't have to use fish
and game funds revenues are pretty flat
and the Senate said no
um and that was the end of it for a week
until right near the end they continued
to have those conversations and instead
of providing the money uh specifically
to the pay increase which would have
been basically opened up the box of the
highway fund and all the other dedicated
funds what they did decide to do was
provide a general fund support through
the fish and game fund to leave a bigger
cushion at the end of the biennium in
the event that revenues and Fish and
Game do go down
um reduced invest New Hampshire on row
64.
I think the governor had 30 million
house had 15 million this drops it down
to 10 million dollars one of those
reasons is you're going to see coming up
under HHS instead of funding investing
Hampshire they decided to fund a housing
Champion program which is actually two
below but also 10 million dollars they
received a lot of requests for shelter
rates at homeless shelters and also for
cold weather shelters and hotel stays
and so instead of funding the affordable
housing fund and invest New Hampshire
they decided to fund these other
programs you can see that five million
dollars on row 66 funding housing
program the housing Champions program
which I believe was Senator Perkins bill
which was higher I think it was in the
29 million dollar range well what they
decided to do is to offset that invest
New Hampshire with funding that new
program see how it works and then you
know have a discussion at a later date
up to 65 is a Pulp and Paper
stabilization Center Finance was
approached by a couple of the
um
the paper the form paper factories or
the Mills up in the North Country I
think there's one in the western part of
the state too on trying to help them
with that industry since they are taking
a hit and so the Senate did decide to
provide more than a half billion of 23
to fund that
room 68 Chris McAuliffe Memorial the
Senate moved back to what the governor
had about 500 000 uh they deleted the
State library book removal funding of a
million dollars that was funded in the
governor in the house
they added funds for the Northwood
Meadows Dam of a million dollars they
added funds for 18 million dollars these
are all about a surplus for the Cannon
Mountain Tramway which is a separate
Senate bill that the Senate tabled in
the Senate was in a similar position as
the house house finance will definitely
remember they have 50 plus bills before
them as they're debating the budget
there was over three billion dollars of
appropriation bills that came in in
addition to the budget and so the House
and Senate had an extra task to go
through and to prioritize which ones
they wanted to fund what the Senate does
is they'll go they'll pass it out of the
committee and then table it on the floor
and discuss it in the budget so the
Canon Mountain was one of those Hampton
Beach pier study it was two million
dollars that was table they decided to
give 150 000 for the Hampton Beach pier
study but more focused on accessibility
of Hampton Beach State Park for all
users
um
Bruce 75 is the Hazardous Waste cleanup
fund statutory already exists at story
Authority already exists and then you're
going to see from row 76 through 80.
removal of federal funds from the budget
in total that's over 100 million dollars
of federal funds that the Senate removed
from the budget understanding that
number one these are drinking and clean
water State revolving loan funds from
the federal government related to the
bipart bipartisan infrastructure act so
these aren't your standard
run-of-the-mill annual clean water
drinking water federal funds these are
specifically related to the bipart
partisan infrastructure law as a result
because they are temporary the Senate
removed them out understanding that Des
can come back to a fiscal committee for
that so just between the meals and rooms
change and this change that's close to
um
200 about 100
almost uh 350 million dollars with those
two lineups alone moving the meals and
rooms back off budget and taking these
out so that that gets into their 750
million dollar
cut that they ended up coming to
um food 81 and 82 you'll remember that
the house funded a food waste disposal
position about 100 Grand in 25 the
Senate removed that and they funded the
solid waste management fund at 1 million
instead of 2 million but they also
allowed that fund to be used to fund
that food waste disposal position so it
just chose a different way to get there
with a lower dollar amount that they're
willing to provide
um on page four these are all new when
you see some of these lines 83 84 85 86
and 87 these are all one-time
Appropriations from 23. when you're
looking through Hospital one and you see
it growing from 400 plus sections to 605
sections which is immense for a bill
um each one of these funds has two
sections because it's the appropriation
plus it's the effective date because so
you do we have 189 I think we counted
effective dates of June 30th 2003
related to Appropriations throughout
house bill 2. so if you cut those off
you're back closer to that 400 number
but all these new ones are all two or
three sections that are added to hustle
two that's how uh hustle 2 grows so
large as far as sections cyanobacteria
mitigation loan funds provided a million
pfas remediation fund grants a 2 million
Nashua Litchfield which was a separate
bill there's an interconnection project
9.7 million dollars
offshore wind and Fisheries was about
ten thousand ten thousand dollars
surface water setbacks and then the
water assistance natural disaster
program they did two things they decided
to remove it out of 24 or 25 but not
fund at 5 million to fund at 500 000 so
they're
um two uh decisions that they made there
under transportation Rose 93 and 94 the
house provided additional funds to match
additional federal funds that became
available for the rural and urban
Transit match in 20 in 24 25 is what the
house did the Senate decided to match
these funds we're going to use surplus
funds from 23 from Journal fund and so
that's why there's an addition of 1883
and 23 to fund both those years and then
the corresponding reduction so they
still support the house position it's
from the different bucket on row 94
Mechanical Services Bureau of equipment
the house provided almost 4.8 million
dollars of additional funding and
general funds to the Highway Department
of Transportation the Senate supported
that but again moved it back to 23 they
were able to support the house but also
to keep their budget down
and then on row 98 Senator Dell Center
had a bill for 40 million dollars we did
this a couple years ago we being the
legislature where we provided additional
funds for municipal Bridges and
enforcement funding I think it was about
40 million Senator Dalessandro's bills
with 40 the Senate agreed Senate
finances agreeing to give him 10 million
for additional Municipal Bridge
Appropriations in 10 million additional
abortionment funding goes to cities and
towns and then HHS
the two big ones coming at you when you
look at category five and six on a pie
chart representative Wilder likes his
pie charts if you look at category and
five and six there are over two-thirds
of the budget just those two categories
health and uh Social Services
Pro 102 they decided to reclassify some
youth counselor positions initially it
was over two million dollars that the
department asked for Senate Finance
decided to give him half of that so look
at a million dollars to reclassify the
youth counselor positions to help with
some of that Recruitment and Retention
they did fund on row 133 so new center
overtime funding and then on row 104 251
family service specialists this is one
of the top priorities in order to
recruit and retain family service
specialists at dsweb they needed to uh
reclassify and so this is almost 2.2
million to do that
105. two things happened here this is
the new heights integrated eligibility
eligibility audit the house did fund
that 839 000 in total funds and general
funds in 24. the Senate was provided new
information by HHS that that cost had
come down so it dropped down to 168 000
but they decided to fund that out of um
when I say that Senator also benefits
from later Revenue estimates they also
benefit from
more accurate predictions of spending
levels from the agency so you're going
to start to see some reductions in HHS
because of a Actuarial study on Medicaid
Care Management because contracts coming
back which the actual cost so they
benefit from all that information just
as the days progress and so they did
find out on rows 106 and 107 that we can
reduce General funds almost 2.9 Million
dollars for
consultation and strategic efforts and
move that to um
reduce the general funds and just add
federal funds to find that federal funds
did become available
108 is a federal data services Hub
that's required by the federal
government but no funding so they did
provide a million dollars in 25. 109 is
your state phase down funding this is
your part D this is your clawback
there's 100 different terms for it but
it's a dually eligible Medicare and
Medicaid patients for their drug costs
this is an item where fiscal committee
if you sit on fiscal you'll remember HHS
coming with a couple Statewide transfers
this is one of the lines they're usually
transferring into because of the
enrollment and the cost they are
required to pay out of General funds
this was one of the top two priorities
of the department so they added 15
million over the biennium for that
110 was a benefit that the Senate
finance committee had that the house did
not have and that was information and it
was an Actuarial study of a cost not
only the projection costs of enrollment
but also the cost of care the uh for the
member per month cost under the Medicaid
Care Management program
so they were able to reduce their budget
by 41.8 and 46.3 so almost 80 88 million
dollars of reductions that still provide
the same level of services that the
house provided just with the updated
revenues
Medicaid
management information system mmis
that's 1 11 and 112. Governor had a 23
appropriation of 20 million dollars
house put it into
24.25 and with the federal match because
the Senate was going with uh to reduce
their budget they decided to fund it how
the governor did one time out of 23
provide the ability for HHS to go to
fiscal to accept those federal funds so
that line alone that was another 87
million dollars that they could bring
their budget down but still support The
house's position
um 113 and 114 are small these are arpa
funds these are the only two arpa funds
other than the bipartisan infrastructure
law the only two arepa funding and as
you there's
more than there's probably four billion
dollars of federal funds in the budget
there's only two small Harper ones in
here of you know 600 almost 1.2 million
dollars so those were removed to come
back to fiscal and use that process
because arpa's not going to be here
forever
it feels like it's been here forever but
it's going to go away eventually so uh
115 and 116 is Glenn Cliff home
Glencliff home does take care of the
elderly with some behavioral health
issues and other needs developmental
disabilities Etc
they are funded with a general fund but
they also receive patient income but if
their census is down which it is they're
not going to get that agency income and
then they recognition of that the Senate
provider involves you 0.2 million
dollars in general funds so that they
wouldn't have to reduce their budget
because their census is down and they're
um
the income will be lower because they
still have your same fixed costs of fund
those same services
crisis stabilization services in the
house bill one that's another five
million dollars that the Senate provided
and then rows 118 119 and 120 is
something that division three in-house
Finance try to address this is
developmental Services acquired brain
disorder and children in-home supports
so there is a dedicated fund for these
Appropriations that is restricted
continually appropriate and non-lapsing
to the Department
the house recognized this they were able
to reduce some general funds
and they wanted to budget the These
funds from the dedicated fund but also
the federal match and so they did
so on row 118 you can see a reduction of
50 million dollars what happened is the
Senate finance committee was approached
by HHS saying that they were talking to
administrative services and then carry
forward those funds in budgeting them as
agency income could cause some issues
they're more comfortable if you were
there's a footnote if you go into those
lines and I can email whoever's
interested there's a footnote on those
lines recognizing that the amounts
appropriate in a house will one are in
addition to those funds that are going
to be carried forward and it's higher
than this 51 and the the five almost 56
it's probably 70 million dollars of
funds that are sitting there in these
dedicated funds that weren't spent for
Dede ABD and in some supports a lot of
that because of utilization but also the
inability to find people to provide that
care but those funds automatically
caring for with statute so between that
and the other funds that's another 65
million that the house was able to so
the Senate finances was able to reduce
their budget by but still support The
house's position
um there was some other funding for New
Hampshire hospital security about three
hundred thousand three hundred fifty
thousand dollars
um
on page five
Medicaid unwind funding so this is the
result of the public health emergency of
the emergency going away on National
level there was the governor provided 16
million dollars because that that ended
the state of emergency ended and people
are de-enrolling unenrolling from
Medicaid Medicaid they initially this
HHS the governor decided to put 16
million dollars aside in 23 just in case
well that just in case never came to
fruition so that 16 million they did not
have to spend for Medicaid unwind HHS
does believe their budget Appropriations
are sufficient and just relative to DD
because DD is one of those developed the
services and development with
disabilities one of those big items in
one of the second largest funding items
in HHS when you compare it to 2223 even
with that reduction of the 56 million
dollars from those dedicated funds even
though it's still available it's still a
22.6 increase over 22 23 dollars so so
that as in Rec there are plenty of funds
the department was comfortable so I just
wanted to before I moved on mentioned
that TANF maintenance of effort funding
on row 125 is another 500 000 that they
added the house had reduced they asked
for it back they being HHS increased
funding for system of care residential
rates you're a member of four Amendment
a DOT believe there's a four amendment
in the house that added 5 million to the
system of care
the HHS came back to the Senate asked
them if they're willing to add
additional money and they did they added
another 11 and a half so the 16 and a
half in House Bill too for the system of
care in total between one and two for
system of care I think it's about 67
million dollars of support for that
program
127 is homeless Services that's 10
million so when you're looking at your
reductions of the house affordable
housing Fund in those other areas this
was one place the senator Bradley
thought was a bigger need for Senate
Finance when they were having their
debate
um and he thought eight million dollars
for shelter rates for homeless shelters
and two million dollars that will go up
to cities and towns to help them in the
event there are any homeless shelters
you can at least provide people with
cold weather
shelter in an hotel or other other areas
and then I will run through just kind of
the big ones Early Childhood mental
health health that's row 130 that's a
million dollars home visiting programs
about 450 000
uh 2 million for Family Resource Centers
the both the House and Senate and House
Bill 2 have a million dollars a year and
24.25 already this is an additional 2
million dollars in 23 so it's a total of
4 million across those three years
recovery friendly Workforce program of
2.1 million dollars that was something
the Senate was approached I Believe by
the governor's office says one program I
offered the house removed I'd like to
have it back in and that's something
they agreed they would do juvenile grief
peer-to-peer Services about 500 000
Juvenile Diversion on row 135 there are
funds in the budget for Juvenile
Diversion the department did ask for an
additional
additional funds so what the Senate
decided is they'll give them 600 000
from 23 in addition to their budget
amounts but also another 300 000 a year
and 24.25 to provide those Juvenile
Diversion services in the counties
uh 136 and 137 those house members have
been around here for a while Senator
Dallas Andrew for years probably over 12
years now has been pushing to have
Foster grandparents in congregate
housing and passed uh added back into
the budget it's been suspended those two
programs along with continuing along
with graduate medical education programs
for since 2011 uh the Senate initially
said no in the uh denied uh
Amendment but later on in the week they
came back and decided we will provide
you with for the next biennium for 24.25
with Foster grandparent funding about
two hundred thousand dollars in
congregate housing of about one and a
half million for the next two years it's
about 750 a year
funded a new system of care for healthy
aging so not for the children which the
regular system care is really geared
towards but this is for the elderly
aging population
it funds Public Health Department
vaccine Administration for standard
vaccines for any public health
department that needs assistance and
isn't receiving Federal sport to do that
they do have some general funds here you
do have Medicaid coverage programs for
mothers so this is row 140. you'll see a
negative 200 in the house column and
that's because the house provided two
hundred thousand dollars for postpartum
care for Medicaid Medicaid postcardinal
care the Senate deleted that but funded
it at six hundred thousand dollars in
23. so 600 of that 1.45 million is
related to postpartum care the other
funds are related to donor breast milk
Doula care and other services to women
WIC Farmers Market nutrition programs on
row 141 the six hundred thousand dollars
of General funds in addition to the WIC
funds that are available
um from the federal government brain
health public awareness 142 there was
also a Senate bill that they
appropriated five hundred thousand
dollars in 23 to fund that one of the
larger Appropriations that they had and
they added near the end of their process
and a finance process row 143 is child
care Workforce assistance there was a
Senate bill that appropriated I think
was 15 million dollars but it was an
um an ongoing Child Care Workforce
Development Fund the majority of the
finance committee decided we support it
but we don't want to make it an ongoing
program we know we have funds in 23 that
you can use over the next couple of
years so we're going to appropriate 15
million dollars for the purpose of
Recruitment and retaining Child Care
Workforce using the structure of that
child Workforce Development Fund just
not setting it up in RSA and making an
ongoing win programs graduated Public
Assistance the so-called benefit Cliff
another 200 000 was appropriated and
then a small one 145 it's small for 46
048 but what it does is doit and Fish
and Game need some assistance from
Department of Information Technology and
they were willing to pay for it if the
legislature paid for it so the
legislature did provide certain Finance
they provide this to them
category 6 is where you're going to see
a lot of your big changes from the
general and education trust fund and as
I stated previously the big decision and
was one of the the decisions that
happened near the end was
we as the center finance committee where
are we comfortable with this tax Blitz
in Senator Bradley was
59-41 not which is roughly current law
between general fund and education trust
fund of business taxes not 60 40. not
rounding up not going anywhere else so
it was 59.41 that is put into statute
that way that actually makes it easier
for Dra to report because now when the
business tax come in they'll be split to
the various pots instead of the current
system where they have to look at which
tax is applied which year when was it
increase and how much goes to each one
so but what you're going to see in rows
149 and 150 has a no net impact here
general education trust fund on a
combined basis but does impact each fund
your other state aid your building a
tuition and transportation special
education building a lease was going to
be moved to the education trust fund
based on that decision at the standard
Finance keep the status quo in the split
so that's a reduction in general funds
of 89.2 and 89.4 doesn't really help
them get to the at 750 million Target
that they had because you're going to
see in the second line education trust
fund because currently in 23 building a
tuition Transportation special ed are
funded from the general education trust
fund it was moved back so that's a net
zero adequate education Aid including
Charter School tuition they added
roughly if you take into the the two
lines
the one below it is a surplus statement
adjustment based on the house proposal
and education funding so it's about
eight and four it's almost 12 million
dollars that was added relative to
adequate education and I'm going to do a
terrible job explaining what this does
Mickey's behind me and feel free to talk
to him after but basically the Senate
was in a position where the house knows
what the Senate proposed and the house
had their own proposal and they wanted
to put more of the money to the property
of poor communities the Senate was put
in a position where they wanted to do
the same thing
but they wanted to get rid of the
stabilization Grant unfortunately when
you get rid of the stabilization Grant
you're creating the same communities
that you're trying to keep
hold hold harmless and keep whole and
provide the additional money to
so Senator Lang worked with Senator
Bradley and department and the
governor's office to come up with in met
with a couple of the house members to
come up with their plan to Target uh
some of those additional funds yes
increase base adequacy but put more of
the funding put a lot of funding into
those um it's called extraordinary needs
which is based on free and reduced lunch
uh man I believe the property tax
evaluation per pupil so that was a big
change even though it shows a small
amount here you'll notice in the end of
this packet is a town by town that shows
the three proposals so
it's more than just the dollars when it
comes to education funding
153 reducing tuition and transportation
Aid of about 4.4 million dollars they
were approached I Believe by the
department and with just some concerns
of a maintenance of effort and ongoing
maintenance of effort once you're at a
certain level in tuition Transportation
you have to maintain that as a result
the Senate did take this reduction of
about 4.4 of the by name again
centimates tomorrow I'm sure there'll be
four amendments on a lot of these issues
where you'll see that reduction uh court
ordered placements 1 454 and 155 similar
to 149 150 is more just moving court or
places back to education trust fund
where it is now because they didn't
change their splits uh episode of
treatment
excuse me that was a house bill the
house decided to fund that as 4.1 and
5.1 and that's related to court order
placements but also special education
services for those kids who can't
receive those services in in the public
school and need an outside entity
these are additional funds right now the
school districts are absorbing those
costs in their existing budgets and so
this the house did decide to provide
almost 9.2 million to take care of this
issue uh senate had pulled that out and
then later on in the process decided to
fund it and similar to court order
Replacements to fund it and special Aid
to fund it from the education trust fund
so they appropriate 19.2 million in 23
for the next biennium per episode of
treatment so they support The house's
position on episode of treatment and but
they'll fund it in a different manner
Medicaid direct certification 158 this
is related to your free and reduced
school lunch population Medicaid direct
certification will kind of cut down a
lot of that paperwork for the cities and
Community School Districts relative to
free and reduced lunch meals and
applications it was something that the
house had proposed there was also a
separate bill the Senate decided to
remove that and to establish a study
committee not only on Medicaid direct
certification but also on the increase
to their free and reduced lunch
threshold of the federal poverty level
so as far as this budget's concerned
there was about 320
000 that was budget because the larger
impact of Medicaid direct certification
happens next by any because it does
require uh Federal approval and some
startup time for the districts to get
ready so right now again this is one
item we'll be debated on the floor
tomorrow but as of right now the center
finance committee is removing that they
delete it Senate Finance the teacher of
the year funding of 250 thousand dollars
Sugar River Valley 16161 House funded it
with General funds because they had the
general funds ctes if you remember
recent memory is they were funded out of
the capital budget
um Governor proposed funding uh the
education trust fund house general fund
the Senate decided to fund it out of the
education trust fund and 23. so you can
see on row 161 but they didn't stop
there because uh the next one down when
it's gone Regional CTE when the house
passed the budget you had 7.6 million in
household 25.
when the Senate adopted House Bill 25
the capital budget they had the same
7.65 million because they made very
little change at the household 25 that
the house proposed
but recognizing the amount of money that
was in the education trust fund
recognizing the additional cost of a
bond
you'll see it's kind of a unique section
where it negates the bond authorization
in House Bill 25 and instead funds with
7.65 so what will happen if both bills
pass
that project for when a Squam will be
funded with education trust fund cash
rather than a bond
deletes the division of analytics
position that was funded provided
funding for new full day kindergarten
programs as they they were notified by
Doe that two districts did approve new
kindergarten full day kindergarten for
the fall it could be Miss Scenic you
know when a Squam I could be wrong but
they did put that money aside to fund
those on page six computer science
professional development program four
million it was one of the last ads that
the Senate added against 23 Civics
textbooks Governor had two house had
zero senates proposing one Center
Finance additional funding for adult
education five hundred thousand dollars
of additional funding for adult
education programs At Doe I believe that
was Senator Rosenwald
funds 168 in educated recruitment
program you'll see it on here that was
the Senate bill but they are requiring
them to identify arpa funds or Esser
funds the elementary and secondary
education funds that are available from
the federal government
and then provides additional funding for
the public school infrastructure fund
the commissioner approached Senate
Finance to ask for or notified them of
almost 21 million dollars of
applications they received for security
upgrades at Public Schools the Senate
was willing to fund 10 million dollars
of that out of the education trust fund
and then 170 the snap for introduced set
aside because when the house
adopted their business tax splits they
wanted to make sure before
funding closing out the education trust
fund that they at least
recognized the fact that the snap free
and reduced lunch back in the fall the
official committee approved an increase
for snap
which is the food stamps to 200 percent
um as a result that had an impact on
your free introduced count and so the
house wanted to set aside 10 and 20
million dollars kind of just a
placeholder because you didn't want to
throw the educational trust fund into a
situation where those numbers started to
require additional General funds the
Senate removed that because of the large
balance they have in the education trust
fund similar to what the governor had he
had a large balance to not have a free
and reduce set aside that money is
already authorized in statute it will
come through the normal uh the regular
traditional adequacy calculation and
then 17172 are not
um
mistypes there was a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars for a charitable gaming
study commission
um and because that was so good Senate
Bill 51 passed with 250 000 for the same
study of charitable gaming so there's
four hundred thousand dollars between
Senate Bill 51 and House Bill 2 to study
charitable gaming in New Hampshire uh
police standards and training 173 was a
new court security officer training
program the Jewish grants approached
police stands in training asked if they
would certify and train and license
their um their officers the court
security officers and they agreed to if
they could they did need a couple
positions and so that was funded by the
Senate reduced dual and concurrent
enrollment is 750 000 reduction in each
year it is above the good trading
between the governor and house level I
think that the governor had about 2
million house had about 3.25 and so the
Senate is right about two and a half a
year the promise program at ccsnh
initially removed by the Senate of 3
million a year and then a week went by
in ccsnh and other those interested in
this program did convince Senate Finance
giving to provide three million dollars
one-time appropriation for the promise
program which is to provide tuition
assistance to those Pell eligible
students first responded career
development program a million dollars
that was a separate Senate Bill there
was a reduction to the usnh funding of
200 024 and 6.2 million and 25 and that
was to bring them down to 190 over the
biennium that's why you have the
different numbers they were a little
higher in the second year so that's UNH
will get 190 million over the next plane
which is about 12 to 13 million over
what they received on the current
binding
house deleted the interoperability of
blockchain program and funding that's
one and a half million and then added I
think senator
in as possibly a three million dollar
appropriation to the university system
of New Hampshire to be matched by the
university system so that Plymouth State
and Keene State received additional
support So three million General funds
they're hoping that usnh will provide an
additional 3 million so that Plymouth
and Keane will receive the additional 6
million once you add that match
and then other adjustments this is more
LBA type stuff but on row 183 increase
the general fund lapse due to Statewide
position vacancies it's two and a half
and five million not big when I show you
the lapses for the general funds the
state does have a 20 plus percent
vacancy rate high as 40 highest 60 in
some agencies so what a lapse is is
basically Appropriations that aren't
going to be spent and what happens is if
you're budgeting over two years and you
want to make sure you have the proper
positions you'll receive that funding
but what happens is people retire you
can't fill those positions or maybe it's
a little longer to fill and so there's
what we call the labs basically unspent
money and so that's something the
legislature looks at and then 184 and
185 when statutory Appropriations for
the general fund like your abandoned
claims
in any other statutory Appropriations
that don't require a fiscal or any other
settlements workers comp claims they had
to add they being Senate Finance about
five and a half million over what the
house had and that is just because the
year-to-date activity that's a number
that I'll put on my office will put on
uh separate from any vote we're just
reflecting the actuals same with
education trust fund 10.3 million over
what was drawn on the they call them
warrants against the education trust
fund automatically via statute to pay
for adequacy and all those costs so it
was 10.3 Higher by the time the Senate
completed their work then no so in total
in 23 the Senate did add 80.5 million
dollars of additional funds total funds
about 30 million in general 50 million
in education trust fund 20 million of
that is that the CTE
but they were able to get there with the
additional Revenue with decisions they
made on some of the under funded accrued
liability and some of those other
programs
and then 24-25 if you add up your 389
and 365 you're pretty close to your 750
that the Senate you're going to hear the
three quarters the billion dollars in
how does that hit the general fund is
roughly about 320 million
um but that's because of the move of
some of your other state aid back to the
general fund in addition to reductions
education trust fund increased by 89 and
72 again because of the move back to the
education trust fund when compared to
the house of all those your other state
aid programs federal funds 135 and 108
so almost 240 million dollars of federal
fund reductions as a result of that
bipartisan infrastructure law was really
the largest ones and then any of the
matches at HHS that they no longer have
to carry for 24.25 very little Highway
funds very little fish and game funds
and then other fun changes 184.2 and 158
124 of that's coming from your meals and
rooms because it does have that fund a
dedicated fund separately as well as
your other funds for that carry forward
for the DD services so
that's how the Senate got to where they
um the current budget that they have on
page seven is the journal fund and it's
more just an illustration of decisions
made during the governor's phase that he
had what the house made the senate for
the three years and you can see the
variance of just the revenues themselves
if you just look on row six you can see
that the house 2.08 almost 100 over 100
million lower in the Senate but that's
because of the business tax split change
you're going to see that number in ETF
and revenue will be higher in 24 and
then 1.881 compared to 206 1 and 25 and
budget Appropriations following that
Labs estimates just point out quickly it
looks like the house made the Senate
finances making a big increase in the
lapse estimate but when you go to 11 on
the lap system the government had 129.9
the reason the house is at 109.36 is
because they had allowed HHS to use some
of their relapses on the mmis on an
ongoing basis because the Senate agreed
with the house or the governor on
funding it from 23 instead they bumped
their laps back to 129.9 and then added
another 30 million dollars in laps
because of the house bill 2023 the
energy bill which didn't have the pickup
that was anticipated so right now the
laps estimate is 159.9
I don't have a crystal ball but because
of the vacancy rate I would not be
surprised if that's higher but by the
time we close up the fiscal year over
the last couple years we're pushing
close to 200 million dollars in the
second year of the bionic for a lap so
it's just a we don't know how high it
will go and that's one of those mystery
numbers we don't find out until three
months after the close of the fiscal
year but uh it that's just something to
keep an eye on but apps in any
legislative action any if the lapse does
increase that's just additional money
that goes to the general fund unless
there's other decisions made between now
and then
um
and then 68.7 going into the rainy day
fund in 23 and 3.2
revenues if you want if you're
interested in revenues or in ways and
means you can see on page eight the
general fund revenues the split between
so these are your Standard current law
Revenue so this won't impact any of the
split decisions or anything so you can
see the governor in 23 was at 1.948 with
the newest numbers and it's over two
billion dollars of Revenue to the
general fund which is one of the first
times we're that high in 24 the governor
about one a little under one nine house
at 1.187 in the Senate at 192. these
zero base estimates and then the
governor at about 1.872 house pretty
close uh and 25 10 million below and
then the Senate at 1906 based on
Collections and but that does show a an
estimate of decreases in 24 and 25 and
your base revenues that reflect all the
action that the legislature took I will
not go over Rose knife uh page 9 10 and
11 but on page nine when you when we
talk about splits and you talk about
Revenue adjustments and why is the
Senate has such a big education trust
and balance you're going to see in the
journal fund right on row eight your
total adjustments so I just showed you
the base Revenue estimates from the ways
Means Committee on current law but you
can see the governor had about I think
it was about 75 million dollars a year
in additional General funds as a result
to his switches on two and three the
house had about 220 million dollars a
year that went to the general fund for
the benefit and the Senate was about a
million dollars a year because they kept
them close to current law so uh if you
look on row eight you can see between
the house and the Senate almost a 220
million dollar difference between what's
available in the general fund the two
months available in the education trust
fund and then same thing in uh on row
eight all the way up to the right hand
column
row nine is all your if you're
interested to look through this or have
questions let me know it's the governor
House and Senate in those areas where
you see like if I look to the state
employee pay raise in row 28 when you
see all the numbers the same that means
it was in the governor House and Senate
budget if it was in you know wrote down
133 you'll see it House and Senate
budget for electronic licensing if it's
just in one the Senate column that means
it's a new program and so look for a
hospital 2 Section these are all in
House Bill two all these adjustments
so there are several pages of that on
page 12 just to give you a size of
magnitude of 23 spending so counting
almost 300 million dollars of
expenditures from statutory law but 200
plus 20 million plus of Appropriations
in 2022. in 23 above and beyond the
budget that was passed two years ago in
2021 the Senate is estimating spending
about 618 million dollars over half a
billion the house had about 538 million
and this is because of the additional
Revenue that's coming in over plan
um it's significant and it's not
something that is
that I've seen where we've had two
straight years of over 400 plus million
of Revenue above plan but
um you know as a result the legislature
made some decisions on what their
priorities were on what to spend and
then in 24 and 25 you can see a
different Appropriations adjustments the
house at about 168 Senate at 130 again
25 million events related to the
retirement and then 181 and 143 and 25.
and then page 13.
and sorry if I'm going slow I did the
center presentation about a half an hour
because I heard it for the last
month and a half so just making sure
that it can try to give you all the
information you have uh prior to their
floor vote tomorrow
education trust fund
um 23 Governor House and Senate uh all
come under an eight million dollars
forward Revenue pretty close between 30
million dollars between the governor
House and Senate and that's current law
and your Appropriations at about 109.6
and then 1146 and 23 you'll see why the
Senate is upending total Appropriations
because you're CTE because of the public
school infrastructure fund and those
other uses so the current year balance
in the governor's 113 house 75 Senate
knowing that the education trust fund is
going to have a big balance at the end
of 25 spent a little more current year
balance just current year revenues is 25
million added to the 108 on Row one is
133 million in the Senate's position
compared to 183 at the end of 23 current
law current business tax splits Etc
we'll move over to 2425 balance boards
are the same it's the revenue so if you
look at the governor's total revenue
into the education trust fund and that's
assuming a
65-35 split 65 internal fund uh 35
education trust fund he's at 1.217 the
house at 77.5 general fund 22 and a half
percent education trust fund is at 1.04
so there's that 200 million dollar swing
and then you can see the Senate kept it
at 59.41 so it's even higher uh so the
Senate has 41 percent of business tax
revenues go into the education trust
fund versus the 35 that the house had uh
the governor had I'm sorry so 1.276
offset by
1.221.6 million dollars in Revenue so
the education trust fund is growing 18
you see another 54 million dollars added
to the education trust fund bringing the
total balance to 187 and that carries
fourth into 25 and that's what happens
in the Senate you have a higher Revenue
uh Appropriations that are lower than
those revenues so the education trust
will grow in their clients in a finance
plan by the end of the by any uh ending
at 236.3
excuse me 236.3 million dollars sitting
in the education trust fund at the end
of 25 compared to the governor's 148. so
that's uh in the house had they're
pretty close remember that set aside the
house had about 30 million dollars to
make sure the education trust was made
whole so they did have to transfer some
education General funds to make the
education trust fund hole in the house
plan
we go over to row 14 you can see the
revenues
they're actually thesis current law so
this is the current business tax place
and you can see the governor at 1.2
House and Senate pretty close in 23 for
Education trust fund revenue and then uh
pretty close the governor had 1.2 1292
house in Senate within 14 million
dollars of Base education transfer in
revenue and then about 10 million to 11
million in 25 is how close they are when
your base revenues
and then your adjustments of um again on
row five is your total revenue
adjustments you can see the large the 75
million I mentioned that this Governor
moved over uh from the education trust
fund to the general fund by changing
those splits house was at 223 1.1
million is what the Senate was because
they wanted to stay as close to current
law as possible and you can see in 24 25
very similar and then the major
difference I think you're going to see
is in 23
are your additional 23 education trust
fund Appropriations uh Sugar River
Valley winnisquam Public School
infrastructure fund episode of treatment
Etc and then there's neither the house
or Senate funded on row 14 the 75
million in additional School building
eight that the government had proposed
EFA appropriation reduction that was
adopted on the house floor this Senate
kept it identical to what the house
passed so it's the same funding level
same parameters that the the house
passed on and then you can see the
settings it's coming off on Row 18 just
because of the balance and that fund was
part of that decision
row 16 I won't go down but this is the
highway fund Surplus statement it's one
page it will show you the governor house
and Center Finance where they thought
the bienniums would end I'm going to
jump to 25. Governor had assumed about
13 million dollars
in the highway fund at the end of 25
based on revenues and expenditures in
the house budget that was about 7.2
million and that's including 10 million
dollars in general fund support that the
house provided the Senate maintained
that 10 million of general fund support
to the highway fund and they end about
12.4 million because of higher revenues
but if some other changes to their
Appropriations and then uh fish and game
this keeps getting smaller so fish and
game has its own Surplus team it's a
dedicated fund you can see in 23 the
governor house had about 9.2 million 9.3
million dollars only difference between
the governor and the house or the
revenue estimates Senate Finance jumped
all the way to 11-3 but the reason for
that is because of the two million
dollars in general fund support that the
Senate provided in house bill to so at
the end of 25 the fish and game fund
Governor assumed 4.5 million their
ending balance house had the same 4.5
Senate was closed but then added that 2
million back in 23 so they're up to
Senate point one and that's assuming 7.1
so that assumes current revenues and the
Appropriations provided to fish and game
and then on page 18
is all the state AIDS the cities and
towns and so on the far right is your
Aid by category education environmental
other Highway funds what the actual in
22 was so Statewide 1.22 billion 23
budget at 1.31 billion and then you have
two columns each for each body you can
see what the governor provided about
1.28 and 1.297 in state AIDS the cities
and towns versus the one two and one
three house provided one three and one
three one three two so almost uh 2.63
million billion dollars and then the
center Finance provided 1.35 and 1.324
so close to 2.7
um not really to 2 6 or so
million 2.67 billion dollars of funding
and then you can see just by the where
they are Senate obviously has a couple
one-offs with your CTE
and your um I think the
9.7 million for the national Litchfield
is in there as well and then on page 19
is kind of a glimpse into the head of
Mickey landergan who works uh with us on
education funding and the budget is
never difficult enough you always want
to throw in education funding in there
as well it makes it so much simpler so
um the governor had his proposal the
house had their proposal Mickey was
running various proposals for the house
various proposals for the Senate
but at each change every member wanted
to know well what did the governor do
what did the house do what did the
Senate do not versus current law and so
we put this or Mickey put the seven
column sheet together that 24 25 are
both the same 962 billion dollars uh for
adequacy Grants to towns and you can see
it's a town by Town through the end of
this presentation what did the governor
recommend and how did the towns fare
what passed the house and how did that
fare and then the Senate Finance
proposal the final proposal Senate
Finance this obviously still needs
ratification in the body tomorrow but
you can see the variances between if you
were to put if I were to
organize them a little differently just
for you to see you can see that if you
move the Senate Finance column in
between the governor and a house as far
as those property poor communities of
those with Higher free and reduced lunch
they're kind of right in between the
governor
um and the house so this is a town by
town and we have if you go to our
website on the general court website the
fourth up top the fourth tab is the LBA
you want to open budget and revenue
documents and you will see all of our
briefings
um if you click on Senate Finance you'll
see all there they have recap sheets
where they monitor and keep track of all
their amendments they offer as well as
every education funding spreadsheet by
component that are available as well
so sorry for going so long but I can
answer any questions if you have them or
feel free to stop by State House 101 102
talk to our analysts we'll get the right
person up to give you the detail and
just let us know if you need anything
hi representative
yeah so just a quick question on line 85
the Nashua Litchfield interconnection
project
my talent engineer tried to get involved
in that because we have two wells in
Litchfield
and we're told Hudson isn't part of that
even though we draw water from
Litchfield
and we are part of the sewer connection
with Nashua you can do what happened
so that I'm going to direct you to the
senator themselves
um
sorry that was a it was a Senate bill or
9.7 million as opposed to going to the
other funds so
um that was a decision that the Senators
had I don't know the reasons behind it
um
we'll try to track that information down
with you or point you to the right
senator
could be Rosenwald Rosenwald is one yep
yep
okay
you're welcome
so Mike
um and for example when a lot of this
moving money around like like rooms of
meals tax for example taking it off
budget
should it also be somehow off Budget on
the revenue list like page eight for
example
already is
so
um all the meals and rooms the numbers
that you see
um and your base revenues already
assumed the carve out for the meals and
rooms that are going to cities and towns
so even though it was in the budget it
was as other it was just a recognition
of that carve out so there was no
additional adjustment necessary
so basically absent that carve out the
meals and rooms revenue and your base
would have been 240 million higher over
the bike well look at page eight for
example general fund
yep
so there's no difference between House
and Senate for rooms and meals roughly
for base Revenue correct and base
revenue does assume that carve out
um to the municipal Municipal fund for
that distribution so that 300 so if you
look at meals oh it's already gone it's
already taken out even from the house
side yes even from the house side
Governor houses all have it removed
already but in the house budget it's in
other it showed up as other yes okay
correct my second question is if let's
go to page
let's talk about all the moving of of
money to 23. so for example on page five
so there's a giant list here of the HHS
stuff
um Family mutual Support Services l a
reimbursement
all moving into 23. right yes are these
ongoing programs that are going to come
back
next biennium or these one-time things
um
it varies the homeless Services is a
one-time 10 million dollars is that
something I would consider that up to
the next I'd leave that up to the next
legislature to decide whether or not
they wanted to fund that
um Family mutual supports only fifty
thousand dollars that could be something
ongoing
um
I'm just trying to find one that could
be
peer-to-peer Services juvenile grief
there are some of these programs
although they're getting one-time funds
in 23 by the time uh 24-25 by name is
over they may be ongoing programs but
that's up to the legislature Foster
grandparents in Congress at one time
that just suspension is just through the
biennium
um your Medicaid coverage as you know on
division three is that something that's
ongoing so I think it's a mix
representative
so wouldn't we say it's a bad practice
to to fund ongoing programs with last
year's leftover money
rather than this year's Revenue because
next biennium we're going to find
ourselves way short yeah
it's a practice I wouldn't label it good
or bad it's definitely a practice and
as you know
all of these items are going to be
debated in 26 and 27 to decide whether
or not they're ongoing I think you have
varying opinions on what's the proper
way I think the Senate
on probably 80 percent of all their
Appropriations wanted to make sure
they're one time and 23 and that was the
thought process behind that they
probably do recognize that some of these
may continue in 26 27 Beyond but I leave
that up to the legislature and to make
that determination
one last question the item that's coming
out of house bill 25 are we simply going
to be borrowing less money than we would
have otherwise yes 7.6 million dollars
less correct thank you you're welcome
yes thank you I was wondering if you
could shed some light possibly on
looking at the usnh budget uh
coming out of the sun on Page Six
the reduction uh at 177 that 6.2 million
uh in fy25 uh can you say anything about
how that number was arrived at what that
what the target of that reduction is in
25. you know so the senate had a lot of
meetings
um with UNH both in and and separately
the goal of that reduction was to make
sure that unh's total appropriation was
190 why 190 that was a number
communicated to them by a university
system that they couldn't live with
obviously they would like a higher
amount if the legislature was willing
but 190 was a figure that they could
live with and so the Senate agreed to
fund them at I think it's about
even it's even a nature school year but
190 over the two so about uh 95 in each
year okay thank you sure
all right so that's all I have for
questions again feel free to email any
members of our staff stop by and ask and
pay attention to the floor debate
tomorrow and we're going to pay
attention to see what floor amendments
adopted that could change this okay
thank you